وفيما يقرب العشر دقائق و بعيدا عن عدسات
التصوير تبادل راسا الدبلوماسيه الامريكيه
والروسيه اطراف حديث غير رسمي على هامش
اجتماعي مجموعه العشرين في نيودلهي لاول
مره منذ عام اللقاء اذا بين انتوني بلينكن
ونظره كان قصيرا على وقع تدهور العلاقات
بين واشنطن وموسكو وتصاعد وتيره الحرب في
اوكرانيا بلنكن اراد خلال المحادثه توضيح
ثلاث نقاط وفقا ما كشفه مسؤولون امريكي
اولا التزامه واشنطن بدعم اوكرانيا وان
على موسكو التراجع عن قرارها بتعليق
معاهده ستارت وثالثا الافراج عن الجندي
الامريكي بول ويلان المحتجز في موسكو ومن
خلال هذه المحادثه القصيره مشاهدينا بين
الرجلين اكد المسؤول الامريكي انه كان
واضحا انه لن يكون هناك تغيير في س روسيا
على المدى القريب فيما يتعلق بالحرب في
اوكرانيا روسيا بدورها لم تعلق على فحوى
الحديث لكن المتحدث او المتحدثه باسم
وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا زخاربا قالت
ان بلينكن هو من طلب التحدث الى لافروف
واخر مره التقى فيها بلينكن شخصيا كانت في
جنيف في يناير 2022 عشيه الحرب في
اوكرانيا وحذر حينها بلنكن موسكو من
العواقب التي قد تواجهها في حال نفذت
عمليتها العسكريه المخطط لها
وجها لوجه على هامش محادثات مجموعه
العشرين
لقاء هو الاول منذ ازمه اوكرانيا على ارض
الهند محادثه على عجل لم تتجاوز 10 دقائق
اكد فيها بلينكن لنظيره الروسي ان واشنطن
ستواصل دعم اكياف عسكريا
وحظ فيها روسيا على الحوار لحل الصراع
والتراجع عن قرارها بتعليق معاهده نيو
ستارت للحد من الاسلحه النوويه قائلا انها
تصب في مصلحه البلدين والامن الدولي
كما استغل بلينكن الفتره الوجيزه ليطلب من
لابروف اطلاق سراح عنصر في البحريه
الامريكيه يدعى بولويلان وبحسب المسؤول
فان بلينكن اراد نقله تلك الرساله بعظمه
لسانه الخارجيه الروسيه بدورها اوضحت انهم
مجرد تجاذب لاطراف الحديث ولم تكن هناك
مفاوضات والاجتماعات رسميه